Abercrombie & Fitch was one of the most
popular clothing stores in the world and
early 2000s however after a couple of
harsh offensive remarks from the CEO an
economic downturn the company almost
went bankrupt despite this they have
somehow been able to fend off bankruptcy
and rise once again so how is
Abercrombie & Fitch able to make this
rapid transition make sure stick around
till the end to find out
[Music]
welcome to Haris hobbies
David T Abercrombie established a first
store in 1892 was recently a hunting and
fishing store and it was called David P
Abercrombie & Company Ezra Fitch a
successful lawyer quite a portion of the
company in 1900 and then it was later
renamed Abercrombie & Fitch in 1904 it's
not great success early on and
eventually both of them retired with a
perk on retiring
in 1907 Fitch on the other hand stayed
until 1928 when he told his
brother-in-law
James s Cobb under a Cobbs leadership
Abercrombie and Fitch
acquired several successful companies
and by 1929 they were getting over 6
million dollars in revenue every single
year and over $500,000 in net profit
they took a significant hit during the
Great Depression but nothing more than
any other company but they were able to
recover very well and by 1939 they were
the greatest sporting goods store in the
world they had a very high profile
customers like Ernest Hemingway and
Teddy Roosevelt the company was more
focused on the quality of their products
versus the cost they can offer that and
throughout the 1950s they completely
remodeled their stores they add a heads
of buffalo moose elk and other big game
in the early 1960s the revenue is still
increasing but their net profit was
actually declining
John a cheering the president at this
time paid very little attention tsa's
and stated that they would always have
their special niche to thrive in but by
the late 1960s they had to resort to
warehouse sales in desperation the
revenue was declining in a net profit
was about negative $500,000 a year
Cree's Camus and next president
completely changed the focus of the
company he improved credit practices and
inventory management and cut expenses he
remodeled stores drive more attention to
cheaper products but these efforts
really did not help theirselves in the
year of 1975 and a net called for have
negative 1 million dollars in
Abercrombie & Fitch later filed for
bankruptcy in August of 1976 and
completely closed the doors at the
beginning of 1977 but this was clearly
not the end of the story Osmond invested
1.5 million dollars into a company and
revived it in 1978 he opened up a couple
of stores and sold a hodgepodge of items
but he realized struggled to develop
identity for the company he received a
lot of criticism that he should just let
the company die but he continued
nonetheless in 1988 linear brands who
had previously been successful at
popularizing Victoria's Secret and
Express acquired Abercrombie & Fitch for
47 million dollars
in 1992 the infamous Mike Jeffries would
be appointed as president would
eventually become CEO and chairman sally
frame cos øx
interest a company to a strong emphasis
on apparel and together Michael and
Sally really popularized the brand among
teens as a sports part of the company
was dying out Michael says that he
target the teen market which he was
growing at record rates he thought that
this could really financially help the
company and he was right as they grew
rapidly building doesn't have straws
across the US during the mid-1990s they
went public in 1996 and by the late
1990s they were building stores have
ranged from 8,000 to 20,000 square feet
in 1998 he dressed Abercrombie which
targeted ages 7 through 14 in 1999 they
faced a three-tier class-action lawsuit
they were just one of several American
Apparel companies are accused of using
sweatshops sweatshops are simply just
clothing factories where the workers
have paid really low wages but despite
these issues
Abercrombie was fish was entering into
its golden years as they made over 1
billion dollars of revenue in 1999 by
the end of
in 90s that over 212 stores nationwide
and then each of these doors we are
making over 400 dollars per square foot
in the early 2000s Abercrombie & Fitch
was the sixth most popular brand among
teenagers even before levees and
Nintendo Abercrombie & Fitch started a
new brand pleasure Cove in July of 2000
it was based on Southern California and
surf lifestyle and was targeted at high
school students Hollister was so
successful that I actually started to
eat into revenue of Abercrombie & Fitch
as a result Mike Jeffries decided to
turn Abercrombie & Fitch into luxury
brand he started using higher grade
materials in the clothing he also
increased prices and bought the
trademark casual luxury he also used
heavy promotions that uplifted the image
of Abercrombie & Fitch into a nerd
luxury brand soon enough he introduced
another brand called rule number memory
5 for older consumers this was
established in September of 2004 and I
was targeted at the age group of 22 to
35 revenue continued to increase and
they opened their first flagship store
in 2005 in 2006 they start a Canadian
expansion opening through Abercrombie &
Fitch and three Hollister stores in
Toronto and Edmonton they also open a
West Coast flagship store in the Grove
the revenue continue to skyrocket in
reaching three point three one eight
billion dollars in 2006 which is wonder
half billions more than a year before
that
in March of 2007 they opened their first
flagship store in Europe in London to
this day this is one of their most
profitable locations and in just the
first six hours of operation they made
two hundred and eighty thousand dollars
in revenue in 2007 they reached the
record revenue at three point seven four
nine billion dollars but this was to
start of your second demise
throughout the 2008 economic recession
Mike Jeffries refused lower price points
or offer sales
he stated that this was in an effort to
protect the brand image and by offering
sales and discounts this would tarnish
your brand image as a lock
brand this let's have first fall in
recent history of revenue to three point
five four billion dollars 2009 they
struggled more financially and the
active firing 50 employees in January
and one or seventy more employees in
Maine in June of 2009 they announced the
closing abroad number 925 by 2010
despite these financial struggles that
continued to open flagship stores across
the globe
they opened a flagship store in Milan in
October of 2009 and a flagship store in
Tokyo in December this was the first
Abercrombie & Fitch store in Asia and it
was the biggest retail moment in history
on the very first day this store alone
created five hundred fifty thousand
dollars in revenue in the start of 2010
they launched a epicures which
highlighted their philanthropic efforts
more stores continued close with 60,000
10 and 50 more in 2011 but closing all
these stores and reducing the footprint
was actually helping the profits of
Abercrombie & Fitch and by September
2010 the profits were actually
increasing they were the first of all
their competitors to recover from the
economic recession they continue to open
flagship stores in Europe with
Copenhagen in November of 2010 in Paris
in May of 2011 at this point they were
continued to expand globally while
shrinking the US footprint in February
2011 they announced they were closed 180
more Us stores by 2015 they had suffered
from the economic recession just like
all the other companies during that time
period but by reducing their footprint
they were actually covering very well
they're actually financially profitable
but all of this would change in 2013
Mike Jeffries was a very smart and
growing brand image and he believed that
brand image was king in the apparel
industry in terms of long term growth
it's very ironic that he himself would
kill the brand image with a couple of
nasty remarks in May of 2013
he pretty much proclaimed that people
who are not skinny did not belong in
Abercrombie & Fitch stores this clearly
caused that outrage in a public and
helped surface 2006 remarks as well
where he said that average
features only for a cool kiss and that
people could not look good to not belong
at the stores this remark or largely
went unnoticed in 2006 but right now it
was making headlines this also helped a
back treatment of the staff members to
also surface this results an explosive
backlash for employees and consumers of
skills never seen before and this was
definitely a historic moment in the
retail industry at this point the value
of appra common features directly
associated with the remarks of the CEO
as Mike Jeffery had pointed out for
several decades brand name Reggie was
pretty much everything in this industry
but now he had tarnished it himself he
had no choice but to leave due to
significant disapproval in 2014 but
despite him leaving his controversial
word led to a global all up for the
company and this turn a becoming pitch
into one the most hated retail stores
for the next couple of years they
abandoned the attractive sales clerk
only policy in 2015 and removed
shirtless models from their stores they
started phase out logos and got a new
creative director in the summer of 2015
for fall apparel was completely
unrecognizable with their usual styles
and they offered all sizes they invested
in profitable stores closed unprofitable
stores and improved part assortment they
were trying very hard to change the
perception of their brand by using new
marketing do you have rid of their dark
shutters and all these improvements seem
to be helping a social image of the
company in a recent survey of the US
adults over the age of 18 most of them
have a better image of Abercrombie &
Fitch in November 2018 as compared to
2016 Abercrombie & Fitch consumer
impression scores went from negative 4
in 2016 the positive 3 in November 2018
Abercrombie & Fitch had also changed
your target demographic from teenagers
to people aged 18 to 24 they're moving
away from all those door styles
completely redesigning them or
completely open new stores altogether in
the last quarter of 2018 it was a fifth
consecutive quarter of increasing same
store sales in 2018 Business Insider
crowd
as the biggest retail comeback of the
year Abercrombie & Fitch
isn't done just yet Abercrombie & Fitch
start as a hunting and fishing company
now absolutely dominate the market
during the first half of 1900s the
company took a sharp downturn right
after 1950s even filing for bankruptcy
in the 1970s Mike Jeffries while
controversial ethic up in a completely
new direction betting its clothing as
cool and fashionable under which a
become and Fitch had the best years but
some remarks along with poor staff
treatment completely destroyed the image
of the company and a knife had to go
into complete rebranding but apricot me
and Fitch was able to fend off
bankruptcy once again I was trying to
become a popular clothing brand again
this company has fought off two
devastating lows during its lifetime and
has one of the most interesting stories
of completely changing their product
lineup but will this be their last major
problem only time will tell but that's
all I have for you guys are a ver common
fish there's a comment down below what
company you elect me and cover next also
you guys like this via the wrench drop a
like and consider subscribing if you'd
like to see more of is just like this
one bundle then I'm worried I'll see you
guys on the next one
[Music]